i certainly am feeling better every day
and kind of more like myself but there
was a period of a week or two after i
caught covered where i knew i wasn't
infectious i
was like going for a walk outside and
strangers scared me more than they
usually do i was
much more socially anxious
talking about whether covid can change
your personality
that what even is that question what are
we on about
so there's a lot of evidence that
viruses and bacteria
try and change host behavior so there's
some really interesting stuff about that
how they might try and change your
behavior in order to make themselves
transmit more easily
but also about how you as an organism
your your goals and priorities from it
from an evolutionary perspective
change a lot when you have an infection
so if you're healthy
you might have certain goals like
seeking out new people to engage with
seeking out new social and mating
opportunities feeding foraging stuff
like that
but when you are sick your fundamental
goals really change
and what i'm thinking about since i
since i just recovered from covid
is about how my personality changed and
how there might be millions of people
who have had covid who now feel
different
and during covid you have this
incredible level of inflammation many
people who are long-haulers and
otherwise have what's called a cytokine
storm
which is a level of inflammation and
when you have high inflammation it tells
your
immune system it tells you that you have
an infection
and that you should behave accordingly
which involves a whole bunch of
different
aspects of personality and behavior
changing so is there a little bit of a
battle going on there is the pathogen
which is trying to find its way around
and then there are the defenses of the
host which are trying to stop its way to
get through
yeah so there are some things that
you're if you think about what you feel
like when you're ill
there are some things that are good for
the pathogen and good for the host
so one example of that is sneezing
sneezing clears you out
it's good to get the pathogens out but
the pathogen also wants you to sneeze
because it's the best way for you
to spray everybody with copies of itself
right
so that's one way in which your
interests are aligned so long as you're
not like sneezing on your kids right
but there's other things where your
interests are not aligned so
fever is one way that you're interested
not aligned the the virus
and the bacteria whatever you're
infected with does not want you to have
a fever
because the fever is really optimal for
you this is why i get very frustrated
when people take
anti-febrile you know anti-fever
medications when they're sick i
i never do because the fever is really
the best possible thing
for you to be uh you know doing
um also you know there's other things
like there's a reason why you're more
interested either in not eating or
eating familiar foods when you're sick
that's because unfamiliar foods might
have pathogens that will compete
for access to your immune system uh so
they'll they'll
be more costly uh and also takes a lot
of energy to digest
so in that sense your body's also
winning and as an appetite suppressant
if a virus or a bacteria could really
properly manipulate you they'd probably
try to make you hungry
[Laughter]
it's um it's interesting thinking about
the individual differences
like what's happening on an individual
level with regards to covid
it's almost all of the conversations
that were having um a medical
rather than psychological and if they're
psychological
they're group differences to do with how
are people's
mental health how is society going to
come back from that it's
never talking about what is it like to
be ill
what are the sort of adaptations that
your genes have just sat
latent in the back of your mind waiting
to deploy as soon as you get a virus
inside of you
there's this word this word that you
sent me an article i learned
can you explain what lassitude is please
attitude yeah so there's you know we
have emotions happiness
surprise fear anger disgust but
lassitude is the emotion of being sick
it's the whole you know so what we think
about as evolutionary psychologists
is emotions are a way to try and
optimize your state of being
in any given moment to solve a certain
adaptive problem if you're angry
you want to punish somebody for wronging
you maybe in the hopes that they won't
punish
me that they won't wrong you again in
the future and when you have lassitude
you are optimizing your behavior uh both
socially
and just alone in ways that are going to
prevent you from
exerting more energy than you need but
also going to help you get people around
you who are going to take care of you
so lassitude is different to
the non-conscious things that you do
like having a high fever
and sort of shivering and stuff like
that is that part of latitude or is
latin latitude more sort of
phenomenological
lassitude is the whole thing but it's
also the feeling of malaise feeling of
fatigue
but also feeling chills you know when we
get angry or embarrassed you also have
physiological changes that happen
uh when you're afraid sometimes you will
[ __ ] right
because you don't want to if you're
running off to be carrying around
whatever it is you're digesting you need
all your energy to run away
it's funny that snakes do this too if
you scare a snake and they just ate
something big
they'll completely throw it up i've seen
that happen
because it's important for them to get
away it's more important than them
eating that particular meal that's the
snake's version of [ __ ] their pants
i mean if you've got like a full
alligator or whatever inside of you
and you try and very quickly digest that
it's just going to end up tearing a hole
in you
uh yeah you can't you can't get away if
you've you know just eaten a third of
your body weight no
so lassitude has similar kinds of you
know it makes you feel
uh cold it makes you feel tired
and also can make you feel very
sensitive to pain and emotionally
sensitive
so there's a bunch of studies where they
injected people with something called
endotoxin
it's basically bacterial particles that
don't really make you sick
but they activate your immune response
as if you are sick
and they found that people are more
sensitive to rejection social rejection
when they've been in debt injected with
this this it's very funny how sensitive
people are to rejection
so imagine this it's this game that
people play where
two people are passing a ball back and
forth in like a computer simulation
so you just see this ball like there's
two players they're like dots
they're passing a ball back and forth
they pass two once and then the whole
rest of the game they don't ever pass
the ball to you
that's the rejection is that
people who you can't even see in a game
don't pass a ball to you
i don't want it i don't want that to
happen though that makes me feel left
out
i want the ball i want to play far more
serious so what ways
are the like talking about food which is
something that you just brought up there
like what why is our desire for familiar
foods
important and why is the change in our
appetite important and useful
i get very frustrated in addition to
getting frustrated with people endorsing
taking fever-reducing medications
i get refreshed with people like you
have to eat something it's important
that you eat
it's not important that you eat so
digesting food takes something between
like five and 15
of your uh resting energy you spend a
lot of your resting energy
uh digesting food but in addition when
you eat food
there's always some chance that it has
some e coli on it i mean everything that
we eat
has bacteria on it and so your immune
system is activated to some extent by
what you eat
this makes sense you know when people
want to eat food when they're sick they
often want to eat really familiar stuff
you know some toast with butter or
some lemon water they generally don't
want to go
to the chinese buffet and you know try
the the pork anuses
or marathon would offer right you really
have a
preference for um incredibly uh familiar
food
and this has also been my experience
with being around people who
are sickly or injured is that they often
really prefer familiar food and they can
be very averse to trying anything new
food wise yeah
so we don't want to expose ourselves to
different types of consumption there
might be some more pathogens in that
which make us even more sick
but the way that that actually manifests
is just
i want something that feels like home
i want something that feels like what my
mum would make
and what that actually is we might
rationalize that as a sense of
comfort which actually is a potential
part of it the familiarity
which we'll get onto but perhaps more
than that it's food that we
know is safe yeah
we have this uh you know as we grow up
this crystallization period so when
we're toddlers we'll put anything in our
mouths
i've seen toddlers eat little dog poo
each other we'll just put anything in
their in their faces and then there's a
period
where your food preferences crystallize
and it's
those foods that you know are safe
because you've been eating them since
you were young
and as humans you know we evolved all
over the planet we couldn't have a set
menu of foods that we could eat
everywhere because you know inuits are
eating
whale blubber and messiah are drinking
cow blood you know there's this huge
variety of foods that people eat
and so it's this period that matters and
so when you want to eat something
familiar
your body is saying i want to eat
something that is very unlikely to have
pathogens that i'm not already adapted
to what about
being needy people get needy when
they're ill why is that happening yeah
so
the you know one very important aspect
of
being human is that you have kin and
friends around you
who can look after you and in our
ancestral past if you had been injured
or sick
and there was nobody to look after you
you could have starved or worse you
would have been very vulnerable
so it makes sense that you want people
around you who are also familiar
who can help look after you and so if
you think about something like
extroversion extroversion isn't
necessarily i want to socialize with
people all the time
it's extraversion is often i'm
interested in meeting new people
and i feel comfortable meeting new
people and
that's prioritizing sort of a novel
area of sort of socializing compared to
the people that you already know
whereas introverts often tend to prefer
people when they're in their social
circle
so if you think about latitude lassitude
makes you want to
invest social capital in the
relationships that you already have
you want to signal to the people that
you know who are not interested in
exploiting you who are interested in
looking after you
i'm vulnerable and i need help and
interestingly they've been a bunch of
studies with animals where they found
you know a male rat will act sick but if
another male rat comes around who is a
rival
he stops acting sick entirely right
these are kinds of studies that are
difficult to do
in humans and so you see this that you
really can't act
vulnerable or sick around uh strangers
and you can't
conserve your energy in the same way
around strangers
but if you think about from this
perspective people who have
um chronic inflammation who have
injuries and who have
infections can be fundamentally
different to be involved in a friendship
or a relationship with
and if you're with somebody and they get
sick or injured
they can really fundamentally change the
way they relate to you and this is
something i don't think people think
about enough you know when you talk
about in sickness and in health
you're really talking about i'm willing
to stay with you
even if your personality fundamentally
changes
from being somebody energetic socially
vivacious
open to experience if you become more
conservative because of illness
i'm going to be willing to stick with
you through that that's the part
the evolutionary psychology adaptation
part
that should have been put as a footnote
in the
marriage details shouldn't it because
what people think when they think of
sickness and in health they think oh
well
maybe you'll lose your job or maybe
you'll
break a leg or maybe you'll need
whatever looking after
but the question of who are you is a
much broader philosophical one
but if something occurs to you which
makes you sick
and that fundamentally changes what we
subjectively define
as you the elements of your personality
that manifest to make you unique and the
thing that we fell in love with
if that changes it it kind of
all bets are off a little bit like that
because you've fallen in love with
someone who's very different to the
person that stands in front of you and
yet you made a deal with that person
that it was
in sickness and in health yeah so
this is interesting that many aspects of
personality that are valued
or that people like about themselves
things like being extroverted people
you know people who like like i'm
somebody who's very open to experience i
like weird ideas i like weird
experiences
i like to meet new people and travel to
new places that's a personality
construct
and that's something that's kind of
expensive from an evolutionary
perspective
there's all kinds of things that can go
wrong if you're not conforming to what
other people
are doing then you're taking risks that
you might not be able to afford
if you have a limited energy budget
because you're sick
these are things you might not be able
to afford if catching a novel pathogen
other than when you already have
is going to end your life and this is
something that happens anyway when women
become mothers
or as people get older they end up
becoming more conservative
because the cost and benefit of
these personality and behavior
things like risk taking extraversion
openness to experience
they start to reduce in relative to the
benefits of just
trying to stay in one place conforming
to what you did before
and you know it's difficult but um i
certainly am feeling better every day
and kind of more like myself
but there was a period of a week or two
after i caught covid
where i knew i wasn't infectious i was
like going for a walk outside
and strangers scared me more than they
usually do i was
much more socially anxious and i was
much more emotionally sensitive
and i talked to my mother every day that
i was sick when i barely talk to her
twice a month usually
[ __ ] so the same thing that we're
looking for with the food is almost what
we're looking for with the relationships
we're looking for that familiarity
something
yeah deploying strategies to elicit
caregiving behaviors from social allies
i think it was put as in that uh yeah
yeah signaling vulnerability as well is
an interesting one isn't it just
perhaps over egging it people accuse men
of man
all the time but the problem is that
we're so good at deceiving ourselves i'm
like
am i as ill as i'm being
am i as ill as i'm making out i don't
know like i'm just
being i'm being me i'm just trying to
[ __ ] get rid of this flu
so this is the thing like faking is
actually a problem and it's a problem
in in societies and there's this great
paper published last year or the year
before
by my former colleague and friend
mikhail dabara irish guy who
i think is at brunel anyway he did a
paper about how
when tribes or people go into battle a
lot of times you'd be like oh you know a
mile from the enemy camp and you're like
oh man i just got this thorn in my foot
it's just terrible i really have to turn
back like
i have this migraine i really have to go
and if you think about things like
trapping like
digging you know putting a hole in
somebody's skull or many of the
horrible cures that they used on people
things like
leeches or drinking your own urine or
you know
giving people mercury or whatever
terrible things that they used to do to
people
these are ways of really making sure
that people are actually sick
if you're really sick then you have to
take this medicine
you know if you're faking it you're
gonna be like actually uh given that the
cure for having a thorn in your foot
before going to the enemy camp is having
your foot cut off later i'm actually
fine i'm gonna go you know with you so
this is a this is a social technology
that people use to make faking much more
expensive
that's so interesting baking is not
expensive anymore as we know from like
how much vulnerability people display
all the time
there's there's very little of
skepticism or cynicism
about people saying i'm really hurt
yeah i'll tell you another thing that's
interesting
about um you were talking about people
getting more conservative as they get
older
i always find it really hilarious every
time in the uk that there's a general
election
because our country's so small that we
can quite easily see the voting
demographic like your country's
basically 50 countries like
stuck together like our country is
actually just one country
well yes four different countries and
all of them hate each other
um what fascinates me and makes me
it always makes me laugh is when people
re uh they get the election map and they
redistribute it based on age
and they go like look look at all of
these old people voting conservative
and you think that's you that's you in
30 years
do you think you're still going to be
bothered about [ __ ] socialism when
you're 65 are you mental
yeah people to have a lot of difficulty
imagining that their future self
is going to be very different and and
honestly there's a lot of anxiety about
changing fundamentally i think this is
part of the anxiety around you know
motherhood and getting older is becoming
a different person
but it it is bizarre especially with
this whole covet thing
being so much more likely to kill
elderly people it really
was a stark contrast to how people in
east asia were treating this
versus people in the west were treating
this on the one hand
complete lockdown inability to say that
we were willing to sacrifice anyone
for the for the greater good of
everybody you know keeping the economy
going
but on the other hand very little
conversation about
who died and and what happened to them
um
you know after 9 11 there was like
moments of silence all the time
for people who died on 9 11. i only
remember one time
that i've been involved in any online
meeting or anything where there was a
moment of silence for people who
who died recently from kovid so i do
think that there's an alienation because
of the
distribution of of deaths does that
relate to the
openness to experience thing of being
sick as well you mentioned about
um some countries with higher pathogen
loads are more conservative and more
conformist
yeah so this is this research and it's
it's pretty controversial
uh randy thornhill uh is the main person
who's
he's you know written a whole book about
it um
he basically talks about looking at the
pathogen load of various different
countries
and then examining things like
liberalism progressivism
religiosity and they talk about how
countries with these high pathogen loads
it's much more important for them to
stick to traditional ways of doing
things
because those traditional ways of doing
things are less expensive than
finding out new ways of doing things but
also things like cooking in a
traditional manner you know that that's
safe you know that avoiding and eating
certain foods
is safe from a pathogen perspective
and there's of course a lot of other
problems with these these countries
people have
criticized this research but i think
it's really plausible
that you would see people becoming more
conformist if they
are sick because the costs of doing new
things and figuring things out on your
own
just become so much greater isn't that
uh
one of the justifications for why many
religions choose not to
eat pork that pigs often tend to have
all manner of sort of nasty creatures
inside of them
pigs are do carry you know zoonotic
diseases
and there's a variety of reasons why
some people
say that in among desert people
like among jews and arabs it would have
been very costly to keep pigs because
they need a lot of water
but it is likely that some of the new
the zoonotic diseases that have
occurred in the last whatever 50 years
h1n1 is a great example
uh was actually passed from very likely
from birds to pigs and then to humans
so pigs have a similar physiology to
humans
we often use pigs in in medical
experiments or
um we have medical students dissect them
because they have a similar
kind of physiology and their you know
when i was reading about covid initially
it also seems very likely that if you
have an animal market where you have a
bunch of animals put together
that if a virus can pass from some weird
animal like a pangolin
uh to a pig then it's going to be much
more easy a much smaller step for it to
pass than to humans
because the physiology of humans and
pigs is more similar than other
animals like chicken okay okay basically
this is part of the reason why i think
it's really important that we
stop doing animal agriculture entirely
that we eat meat
you know that's cultivated rather
instead because um this kind of stuff is
going to keep happening
and there's a you know a great uh piece
by philip lemmon
in colette about how comparing how long
it took china to talk about
uh kovid versus how long it took the
united states to talk about h1n1
um they're very comparable i think
there's only like 11 days between them
and uh it's it's very likely that any
country that factory farms animals is
going to be the next
hot spot for a new pathogen like this
are you familiar with a guy called
cosmic skeptic alex o'connor he's a
youtuber
okay so he's a really good buddy of mine
and i was talking to him earlier on
about this conversation i was going to
have with you
i really want i really want you two to
link up i really want you to go on his
show or
have a conversation because [ __ ] me if
he hasn't
really read pilled me hard i i challenge
anyone to listen to alex
talk and synthesize stuff like peter
singer's work and
and everybody else that's in this space
of like animal rights philosophy i
suppose
and not be convinced by the case not to
eat meat
i i now
have fully accepted that my lifestyle is
not in alignment with my morals
and before having that conversation with
alex that's not the case now i mean he
hasn't
pushed the guilt or uh
degree of care for me sufficiently high
to actually overcome
always eating meat but certainly small
changes i've made like now
uh always almond milk or coconut milk
rather than cow's milk
he did this amazing video where he said
when you go up to a starbucks
kiosk you can stop this entire
vertically integrated chain of suffering
simply by changing one word in your
order by adding almond or coconut or
whatever uh wheat milk or whatever it's
called now uh
i i don't mean wheat milk what's it
called
oat milk oat milk um it's a friday it's
fine
yeah i uh i just really really think
that that space is interesting
at the moment and it seems like the
development in terms of animal rights
philosophy is is
moving along at a pretty terrifying pace
yeah in in brief i'm writing up
something
about how clean meat is what we call it
uh
that's the new the new uh term for it uh
because
lab meat sounds weird and people are as
i've just talked about a lot
are very averse to foods that have
strange names or strange connotations
um but it's really going to be very
important in terms of preventing any
future pandemics for us to do that
and i don't think that the world is
going to become vegan in any way shape
or form
i've been involved was involved very
heavily with the vegan movement for a
long time
and i became very disillusioned with it
because the needle never moved on the
proportion of vegans and
most people who say they're vegetarian
eat chicken and fish
i wrote a piece called practical
veganism about this about how it's
actually better to eat beef once or
twice a week
than to eat eggs every day from a
suffering perspective and cow's milk
matters a little bit but doesn't
actually matter that much in the grand
scheme of things
so you know my point is is basically
um you can make some small changes that
don't involve giving up meat entirely
that can make you cause less suffering
than somebody who has given up
um animal products that you know or who
has given up everything but eggs for
example
i got i had a conversation with someone
who is into
quite green and into saving the planet
and stuff like that
um i've gone down the existential risk
rabbit hole recently with toby ord's
work
and i've got brian christian on the show
soon
is it not mad people who are green but
not vegan is that not like the single
biggest
ironic like misalignment of someone's
values that you're here to try and save
animals from suffering
and yet the most direct cause that you
could find in order to cause suffering
is still there saturn you play
i agree that people who are yeah super
eco warriors and who are into preserving
the sanctity of nature
have a lot to answer for
me and stuff like that but i also think
that nature is
in some fundamental sense of just a
suffering cesspool
we enjoy nature because we evolve to
enjoy nature
i love to see you know a beautiful
panoramic view of iceland or a
herd of bison as much as the next person
but i know that fundamentally
all the animals that we see in nature
especially small animals are
having lives that are terrible um and
many of them are having lives that are
just as bad as animals that are factory
farmed
so because these these ethical issues
are so tricky
and because we evolved in no way shape
or form to consider animals as
as moral agents other than you know
children
and and people learn to understand
animals very well because that was an
adaptive characteristic to learn to kill
and exploit them
the only affinity we have with animals
is actually just a byproduct
of our desire to eat them sorry
i mean cats and dogs are kind of bred to
look like babies that's a kind of
different thing we didn't evolve to eat
them
uh but yeah overall yeah there's a lot
of very confused logic about eating meat
i would say that you in particular if
you're are you like paleo at all
is that what your deal is no just trying
to be healthy failing you just trying to
be healthy
yeah i mean you could absolutely if you
think that um it's important for human
health to eat once a week as i
you know i don't actually think everyone
thrives on a vegan diet that's something
i really changed my mind about in the
last 10 years
and i've endorsed people eating mussels
and and clams and
other kinds of bivalves if you want to
try and cause
very little suffering because i don't
think that those animals are capable of
suffering
and they also fill in some gaps
nutritionally in
a vegan diet but i hope that in the next
couple years there's
gonna be you know chicken that you can
buy that was grown
cellularly uh and you know i i i
predict and people like david pierce the
transhumanist also predicts
that when this clean meat is you know
widely
uh dispersed through the population and
people are eating it when it's cheaper
and considered healthier
than meat off the hoof or from killed
animals
people are going to be incredibly
judgmental about people who eat ordinary
meat
because it's going to be almost cost
free to have that moral attitude
i found that out to do with
our sensation or our love for scandal
why is that we love scandal so much
because it allows us to feel a moral
emotion whilst having to do nothing
moral to achieve it
yeah i mean this is when people people
talk about virtue signaling there's good
virtue signaling and there's also like
really cheap talk signaling people love
chief talk signaling yeah scandal is
like
i can i can morally oppose you and
nobody knows really anything about me so
it's super easy to do
there's a great book uh it's now a few
years old called why
everyone else is a hypocrite and it lays
out the whole evolutionary psychology
of why we're constantly looking for
moral loopholes looking for ways
to indict the behavior of others while
maintaining our own behavior
everybody if you do look at surveys
thinks that they're more moral than
other people
and um actually hating on vegans is a
major way that people try and make
themselves feel superior
did you ever see that film with jet li
it was called the one
okay so it's maybe about 15 years old i
oh i don't know why this film
always comes back to me whenever i have
conversations especially to do with
status
it's it's basically a zero-sum game with
yourself so you can imagine there's like
in the future there's this police force
that polices
all the universes and there's maybe 300
universes
and you exist so there's a diana in all
324 universes
but she's slightly different in one of
them you're an artist and in the other
one you're a full-time mum and either
one you're that but there is an amount
of energy that you have
like kind of like a superhuman and there
are certain people that realize that if
you go through all of the different
universes and kill yourself
you take their energy but the problem is
obviously that over time
all of the other versions of you are
getting stronger too and they don't
understand why
only you know that you're getting strong
because you're killing everyone else
and when i hear about like non-zero some
status games
to do with bringing other people down to
make yourself better i
always think about jet li killing
himself in the one
that's like yeah that's that's a very
interesting trade-off because you know
we evolved kin selection
identical twins you know very rarely
have
terrible fights they're very likely to
cooperate and killing yourself is just
the most perverse thing
i actually went on a date with a guy
this is like 15 years ago um he told me
that he didn't speak to his identical
twin brother
and they fought all the time and i just
thought that was the creepiest thing i
ever heard in the first book again
wow you're right yeah because i mean
what
you would have to adapt if evil if um
you're going to have
identical twins evolution is going to
have to put something in that makes you
help each other live
well yeah i mean we we're all involved
to help people this is a
super interesting study um lisa de
bruyne is a researcher in the uk
who did this interesting study where she
morphed like
let's say you have two different faces
and i morph one of them with a stranger
so it's half
strained your face anyway and then i
morph the other face with your face
so unbeknownst to you it actually looks
like you it has some facial
characteristics in common with you
you're going to be much more cooperative
if i say you're playing a game with
these two people you won't know why but
you're going to be much more cooperative
with the face of the person who looks
similar to you
whether the same sex to the opposite sex
because all of us have these kin
selection
mechanisms and as much as people want to
promote
you know things like diversity and um
harmony in a multicultural society
it's very difficult to escape the fact
that we are just
more generous and and kind to people who
look more similar to us
did you see this study i remember
hearing about this years ago well before
the podcast so it could be total
[ __ ]
not that i fact check anything that i
say on this in any case
um i remember seeing a study saying that
babies young babies are able to tell the
difference between different sheep
and different cows they're able to
detect differences because
they're continually um entranced they're
constantly looking when you show them
different sheep
whereas there's a line around about
three years old i think
where toddlers will look for a little
bit and then although they are different
sheep to them
they look like the same sheep so they
get bored and distracted and look
somewhere else
i imagine i know that this is the same
that white people have a difficulty
in telling similar looking black people
apart similar looking asian people have
a problem with telling similar looking
indian people apart etc etc
yeah this this mum friend of mine she
was really worried about her son
and she said you know we went to this
playground i'm worried that this kovit
is really screwing him up socially
because we went to this playground and
he started playing with this kid
and he was calling this kid the name of
a kid in his class even though that
kid's name wasn't really hudson he was
calling him hudson
and i was like was the kid black and
she's like yeah how did you know
oh my god your kid is having trouble
telling
these two kids apart because of the
other race effect which is well known in
criminal psychology
and this has been a terrible thing for
um
people have been convicted on this basis
because you get a line up
and you know white people who can't tell
neil degrasse tyson from o.j simpson
[ __ ] and that's called the the other
race effect
amazing i love i love having names for
stuff like that right so
latitude surely once you've gotten over
an illness
you're just fine like why would an acute
non-traumatic incident
cause a state change long-term
so there are the coveted long-haulers
these are people who have
inflammatory markers that last for a
really long time
after they recover and covet seems to be
more likely to cause these kinds of
problems than some other diseases
mononucleosis
uh which in the blog i have coming out i
talk about this woman that i know who
had mono and her personality really
fundamentally changed she became very
anxious and depressed
and there's a lot of idea that
depression anxiety other mental health
problems
might actually have something to do with
inflammation so even after you've fought
off an infection
your immune system can still be on high
alert you can still have this this
inflammation
and there are certain other very normal
diseases of civilization
that are caused by this when you are
overweight or obese
you can have chronic systemic
inflammation and
when your body doesn't know the
difference between uh
i have too much weight on me and i'm
actively fighting off an infection
you're going to experience the same kind
of sickness behavior or lassitude in
response to that
so you know your body
this sixth sense that you have where
your body is monitoring
whether or not there's an infectious
agent in your in your body and whether
or not you're fighting off something
it's not going to be perfect and it's
less costly for it to make the mistake
of carrying on with inflammation
than it is for it to stop so you have to
think about this thing it's called the
smoke detector principle
right people have smoke detectors that
go off when they're not supposed to
because that's a better mistake for the
smoke detector to make than for the
smoke detector to not go off when
there's a fire
and similarly when your psychology is
examining whether or not you have an
infection
it's better for it to make a mistake
thinking that you have an infection
than that you don't have an infection
that negativity bias which continues to
come up throughout all of evolutionary
psychology
being reframed as a smoke detector
effect is really cool
does that mean does that mean that on
average
fatter people are more introverted
fatter people are going to be less open
to new experience
i do not know any studies on that and i
like
don't i'm not going to be the person to
do that um i even
uh there was a guy who used to have a
really great podcast called smart drug
smarts
uh now i can't jesse law learns his name
i can't remember the guest that he had
on
but he had on a guest who was talking
about the cognitive changes that come
with being overweight or obese
and people talk about when they talk
about having coveted they talk about
things like
like brain fog because inflammation also
interferes with with mental functioning
but brain fog also might be a way that
people describe
i don't feel like thinking about new
ideas i don't feel like sitting down and
reading
i just feel like preserving my energy
you know even when i was sick i was
watching
you know you i love mitchell and webb as
you may also love
the uh and like peep show and stuff i
was watching clips of things i've
watched hundreds of times
just just familiar stuff that i wanted
to to engage in
and that's a possibility um not just for
you know people who have these kinds of
uh conditions based on like food that
they eat people are always talking about
what foods are inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory
but also potentially you know other
kinds of diseases
like multiple sclerosis
um the last thing i was gonna say
is that there's some studies where they
gave people like an aspirin or i think
it was an advil that gave people an
anti-inflammatory
drug and they examined their behavior
afterwards
and people who were given i think it was
ibuprofen every day
were less emotionally sensitive this was
a small effect but you can actually see
that if you lower
people's inflammation that also changes
their behavior in socially important
ways
wow how does having a pathogen in the
world
change the attraction and sexual
dynamics that are going on
i don't i mean i'm very interested in
how this is going to
to play out so men and women have quite
different responses to infection threats
uh there's some marsupial mouse that i
love to talk about
who uh they only live for one breeding
season and they spend no energy at all
on maintaining their bodies they're
entirely their whole energy budget goes
to trying to have as many matings as
possible
and by the end of the mating season
they're literally falling apart there's
like
infections all over them they're just
riddled with disease and they're still
trying to have sex with as many females
as possible because
that's their whole raison d'etre right
and so
uh in humans you know it's not
definitely not that exaggerated
but men don't conserve their energy
budget as much to try and
maintain their bodies as women do
because for men
mating is much more rewarding
a man can just have sex once and have a
baby whereas a woman
often has to have sex more than once it
can only produce a child
every you know ancestral populations
every four years with nine months of
gestation
and three years on average of
breastfeeding that's what hunter
gatherers generally
do is it takes four years to make
somebody who could potentially become
an adult and also women have to maintain
their bodies better
in order to carry a child sperm is
really cheap and eggs and pregnancy are
really expensive
so you might see even more misalignment
of sexual desire and motivation in men
and women
because women are much more sensitive to
infection threat
and postcovid certainly you're going to
see a dip in libido this is something
that you see with all diseases
but when you look at like male rats and
female rats for example
the males are much more likely to carry
on having sex and not reduce
their libido in response to inflammation
compared
to females so this could have
long-term effects i've become obsessed
with reddit which is called dead
bedrooms where people talk about
their sexual mismatches they have a high
libido partner usually in the low libido
partner
and it's it's fascinating but i think
that these mismatches they happen
usually you know men want to have more
sex than women do
but you could imagine that uh this could
be exacerbated this this mismatch could
be exacerbated by disease or even the
threat of disease
good time to be gay then if you're gay
great time there was that it was a guy
there was that like a hungarian mp
who uh got busted for being in a gay
orgy
and the people who you know in the 1970s
and 80s you'd be like oh my gosh i can't
believe he was in a gay orgy and
nowadays they're like i can't believe he
was in an environment in which he could
have spread covet
that's so irresponsible i hope he was
wearing his mask
i hope he was wearing not that one not
that mask a different one
ian savage was saying that uh he thought
kovid was going to bring back glory
holes
[Laughter]
i don't know if we had i haven't really
been around i've been in new york in
march sorry i'll let you know but
anyone that's listening who has found an
uptick in glory hole usage
during covid please comment below yeah
i mean there's so much that's
fascinating there i
i tweeted the other day saying that
kovid's been fantastic for productivity
and mustaches but awful for
sex like how much of it
aside from the concerns that we have
around viruses being out there
is there um like a restart
to something that's become ingrained in
terms of like someone's habit of
not talking to guys or girls not having
sex
not being open and spending time with
other people is there like a a brief
acute period
that might end up spreading out like are
we gonna have a population dip
in 24 years time or something like that
i think that there's been some
controversy about whether or not we're
going to see a baby dip or a baby boom
you know lots of people who were paired
up ended up spending
all their time together and people i
think who were in couples
who were isolated together probably had
a lot more sex there was just a whole
lot more time
and boredom so that that makes sense
but i as far as i know the the the full
tally of whether or not
there's been an increase or a decrease
um hasn't been accounted for
and i know that some people were worried
that covid was going to have some kind
of long-term impact
on on children doesn't seem right now
like women who catch code when they're
pregnant
have children that have um serious
problems with any kind of birth weight
or anything
but you know what we saw in the
influenza pandemic
this was like a hundred years ago um in
denmark was that there was an uptick in
schizophrenia afterwards
and so there's some psychological
problems
things like schizophrenia or um autism
that you actually wouldn't see until
children were over
were older so we actually won't fully
know what influence covet might have
on pregnant women until you know three
or four or even 20 years down the line
you don't actually have onset of
schizophrenia until you're 25 years old
on average so is that what is that due
to stress
that's due to the psychological profile
of the women during the pregnancy
there are some people who think that
mental illness many mental
illnesses are actually caused by
disease like there's there's some
correlation for example between
having a high fever uh when you're young
having rheumatic fever and having
obsessive compulsive disorder
when you're older so it it makes sense
you know from an evolutionary
perspective it makes sense that many of
the
the ways that psychology changes that
are least adaptive
are some kind of noise that was
introduced into the system
that undermines the adaptive you know
functioning of the system
so it is possible i'm not i'm really not
trying to scare monger
you know coronaviruses are super common
and
it's it's just as likely that nothing
will happen at all
but we do know that that flu is
correlated with an uptick in
schizophrenia diagnosis
why would schizophrenia and
autism be adaptive that's what i'm
saying
but they're not so they're they're
maladaptive but there is some
way that a virus changes the development
of the brain
that makes it more likely so there can
be a nature and a nurture effect here
such that you have a genetic
predisposition for schizophrenia but
unless
your mother had the flu when she was
pregnant uh you won't get it
and um you know there's there's
considerations about this you know when
you see
identical twins who are born um
oftentimes
the smaller twin the one who got
for whatever reason a lower blood supply
of
less placental axis or whatever will
have a different personality
than the other twin so that's a great
example of nature and nurture
that uh this this this guy emailed me to
tell me about
these twins that he knew where one was
much more aggressive
and much more extroverted uh than the
the younger one born a few minutes later
who ended up being smaller
who was much who was basically trying to
get social
capital from her parents and get their
attention in a completely different
strategy
uh by being cute and sweet and quiet
whereas the bigger one was being more
grabby and aggressive
and you know shouty right so we all
figure out the best strategy to get
attention
uh those things are somewhat genetic
predisposed but you know there's there's
also a correlation with extroversion
and attractiveness in men and women
attractive people are more likely to be
extroverted
and men strong men are more likely to be
extroverted and that's because being
extroverted as i said before
is kind of expensive there's a lot of
things that can go wrong and you don't
want to be extroverted unless you can
afford it
in terms of social capital yeah so is
that
i had this conversation with rob
henderson and the penny dropped there
he talked about how muscular men
even in 2021 where we have far too much
food and there's lots of fat people
everywhere
muscular men are signaling i can acquire
excess calories i am so fit and i am so
good at resource acquisition
that look not only can i eat what i need
to eat but i can eat more so that i can
have these
ridiculous things attached to me um does
it seem like the muscles
i'm talking about muscles um
and um is it the same
with extroversion is it look at how much
more outgoing i am look at how much more
i can put myself out there because i
have so much fitness inside of me i have
so much energy and vigor inside of me
and if you mate with me
your children could have this as well
sexy son yeah absolutely i think that
there's a certain uh you know if
somebody's extroverted and they identify
strongly with being extroverted
there's a signaling aspect to that and
they can show off you know how
extroverted they are how many people
they know
how big their social circle is uh but
that's certainly
a lot of i think what social media is
based on is is signaling
that i was confused about the muscles
and the excess calories because to me
like muscles just have like a direct
fitness
signaling they're not really necessarily
signaling i have a lot of excess
calories they're just signaling
i'm i'm strong and uh and formidable
and if you have two different ways of
gaining status you know prestige and
form
and formidability uh prestige is
acquired by being somebody smart or wise
that people want to talk to
you see like the gurus these days or
people who are trying to signal that
they have both
right i can give you great advice but
also you know watch me deadlift this
so do you think those two work against
each other
do you think that it's a confusing
signal to
members of the opposite sex to have that
is it easier to block people into
archetypes um i do think that it's
easier to block people
um into archetypes to some extent but
people who are trying to signal their
both like a really muscular
you know big dude often tries to signal
just as hard that he's like a nice
person
because he recognizes that people are
very likely to typecast him
as like a tough or what what is what is
it that you guys say in
britain if somebody's really built that
their super hench well i mean i
i can sort of attest to that myself
certainly that for
quite a while i tried to downplay my
looks and like overplay
the vocabulary that i would use or the
the things that i would say or the
the way that i would talk and the stuff
that i would cite because i knew that
coming from
my background if people knew who i was
being a club promoter for 14 years
and perhaps the way that i look a little
bit that people were just going to
immediately think fuckboy
so i would i would try my best to
signal no no no enigma
like onion layers like i would try my
absolute best to try and get that to
come across because i desperately didn't
want to be typecast
as that boy despite however much
my history may have no i'm too good i'm
too good looking now i know somebody who
wears glasses for that reason even
though he doesn't need to
because because he thinks he looks
clever in glasses
and uh and i was like i don't wear
glasses he's like yeah you look jewish
that doesn't
[Laughter]
so moving forward there must be there's
going to be like a couple of things at
play
because obviously we have like our
genetics are genes trying to deploy
themselves through our behavior right
and that may be there's been a virus
floating around
to women go go steady you need you need
to be a little bit careful here if you
have
children it's it's costly but there will
be an alternative
system at work which is you and i had
sex in ages
like you need to go have sex so surely
these two things are going to be pulling
against
each other yeah there's there's there's
this whole literature that's really
fascinating it's called life history
theory and it says
people respond to threats differently
depending on whether their fast life
history or slow life history
so still life history means that you um
give birth later
you take care of your offspring for a
long time and you live a long time
whereas live fast and die along young is
like the fast life history
where you're trying to have lots of sex
partners have as many babies as possible
and uh if you get a threat from the
environment
that there's a threat of death around if
you're a slow life history
you might actually try to become more
cautious or try to
engage in in a steady long-term
relationship more likely
whereas if you are a live fast die young
kind of phenotype
you're like well i need to have sex with
as many people as possible i need to
breathe before i die
kind of like those mice that fall apart
that i was talking about and so
the best example of different life
histories is between men and women men
inherently have a faster life history um
on average than women do
but there's this idea that if you
experience hardship when you're young
you're getting cues that the environment
is volatile and unstable
and that it's important that you um
breed quickly there's some
correspondence for example with uh
having early life hardship and having
earlier puberty
that boys their voice strong no way that
it triggers them to go into puberty more
quickly because that would mean that
they're able to protect themselves
yeah and and i knew a guy who who said
that uh
he thinks he would have been like a foot
taller if he hadn't had a stepdad
because
having a stepdad having an unrelated
meal in the house
who was aggressive to him he didn't have
a nice step dad um
sort of made him put his energy into
maturing earlier
rather than growing and this is actually
what you see in in the congolese pygmies
is that they're very very small they're
like i can't remember how tall they are
um but they have much earlier puberty
timing than other groups is because
their strategy is instead of getting big
and tall which is kind of a more long
life history strategy they instead shunt
that energy
into becoming reproductively viable
earlier because they live
in an insecure unstable environment so
this is you know this is a controversial
idea but
if you want to talk to somebody about
this marco deljudice
he does a really great work on this and
he's tried to
translate many different psychiatric
conditions
into this possibility that they they
have something to do with life history
and you do see
uh people's you know their how early
they go through puberty
and various other things about them
reproductively correlate with certain
aspects of their psychology and mental
health
that's mental like the way that our life
experience
can kind of turn on or turn off
things that we presume are like what
like bestowed on us by god or like
immutable truths or like some weird
source code thing that's inside of us
and we're talking about in utero like
before you've even entered the world
[ __ ] can happen that is going to
fundamentally change
the way that your life is going to
happen in ways that you're never even
going to know and you're not able to
split test your own
yourself into a different a different
version where it didn't happen
that's mental are we going to see more
people be asexual
during this period as well i think it's
possible
i mean the the whole controversy about
asexuality and i i'm working on a paper
about asexuality
is whether or not it's a sexual
orientation or whether or not it's it's
a disorder
certainly if you have anorexia not like
anorexia the condition but
what's the biological term anorexia you
don't feel like eating
people say that that's uh the outcome of
some kind of disease
but asexuality is being seen uh less
that way
but i also think that asexuality because
there's this population of people who
are having fast sex with people that
they barely know
now there's this lexicon of people who
are like demisexual i only want to have
sex with people when i get to know them
very well otherwise known as women
are you being serious typical yeah the
demisexual and like gray sexual
um there's this lexicon of identities
that i think correspond to generally
perfectly normal behavior
and some women who are asexual like in
the study that we did i think 75
of um asexuals uh were women
um interestingly there are people who
are asexual
and they uh they're also trans they
start taking testosterone
and guess what happens when they start
taking testosterone they stop being
asexual
right so it definitely seems like
there's something hormonal going on and
it's amazing to me how averse we are
to these biological explanations people
will tell you that you know an offhanded
remark their mother made change them
forever
but they won't talk about how they had
like a fever or they broke their leg or
something
uh and people are really averse to the
idea
that these biological effects really
have
have an influence on their personality i
think it's like modern day dualism
you know i have a soul and it has no
it's not influenced by testosterone it's
untouched by my hormones and
disease what's your opinion
of people being able to step into their
own programming around this stuff then
if you're sufficiently well versed in
evolutionary psychology
and sufficiently mindful and you've done
all of the meditation and you can
observe the texture of your own mind to
the fidelity where you actually perhaps
allow this stuff to manifest in
consciousness because
the front of your brain isn't taken up
like
scrolling through tinder or [ __ ] tick
tock or whatever
what how do you feel around people being
able to pull back some of that
programming and source code
um i feel like i have some insight into
myself
but my self-insight is at the cost of
having an incredibly cynical view of
myself
you know when i think about how i feel
about the people in my life
i know that i love my mother but i also
know that i might have been calling her
more often when i was sick
because i had an inherent interest in
getting more of her investment i know
that i
love my husband but i also know that
if he lost made value or i gained meat
value or if i
became ugly or disfigured that it would
fundamentally change our relationship
we're not two souls together we are two
bodies we are
physically embodied and it's impossible
for us
to get away from that so
what seems like it's going on in the
culture is that people have the strong
desire to think about themselves
as these you know kind of disembodied
souls and
it's not very dignified to talk about
yourself
in in these other more embodied uh ways
i don't think that you can have a
perfect view yeah
i have a close friend who um had a lot
of psychological problems and didn't
realize
until he was 50 that he had had a
serious illness
um and a favor so high that he had a
seizure
until he read some letters that his
mother wrote she had never told him
and it elucidated so much about him
there's so much i can never know about
myself
uh about my birth and about you know my
mother gave birth to me in brazil
and i didn't breastfeed for like two
days because they gave her so many
sedatives
like who knows what i would have been
like if i hadn't been
heavily sedated when i was born i'll
never know isn't it fascinating
that we live in a society now where
people pride themselves on the
rationality
were a meritocracy people are able to
become whatever they want to be i am in
complete control
and yet there is still this
element this sacred
ephemeral religious
sense of us that is outside who i am
people talk about it as if it is this
sort of universal thread gently
gently again and his and his other jet
lies um
people talk about in that way that there
definitely seems to be a little bit of
it's not even cognitive dissonance
because people just aren't aware that
it's happening
but we we do seem to have i would
dualism i think is a good
a good way to put it we think that
there's two different things going on
but it seems like almost everybody at
least in the west
has on this pedestal the utilitarian
rationalist
perspective science is going to be able
to explain everything
and they still allow this who i
am my true sense of being and can become
incredibly upset
and insulted if that gets challenged
yeah
do you know that when someone needs to
urinate it reduces their belief in free
will
no way are you being serious
how why um i think it's because you you
you feel like you're so tethered to
something physiological that you like
yeah it reduces your ability to believe
in free will
so what you were basically just talking
about is this kind of modern day
uh dualism and what i think is really at
the root of that
bf skinner back in the like 1950s and
1960s
talked about something called counter
control that
we don't want to be controlled by others
he was using this reward
and punishment kind of paradigm and in
my view
the more you know social media gets to
know about us the more we have these
findings about sex differences and
things
people don't want to be predictable or
controllable
it's fine on your spotify when your
spotify tells you what songs you're
going to like
but people are really not happy
about being told that they're more
likely to have specific interests
or be able to think about certain things
more easily than other things
um you know the idea that men and women
have different cognitive
styles is now incredibly uh
controversial
and i think more and more people are
identifying
as non-binary or they're not willing to
talk about various things that would
make you able to predict their behavior
i mean just looking at personality
you can predict if somebody is male or
female with 96
accuracy right like if you just look at
a long form personality inventory you
can
detect somebody's sex with high fidelity
just looking at their brains and people
don't like that people don't like the
idea that you can predict
what they're like on the basis of
something like their
sex assigned at birth and um i think
that what's going on
you know is is that this is getting
muddied uh by people identifying
as you know different ways and you know
my view is that some of the
some of that is really identity but some
of it is trying to escape
control i can't believe
that that thing about the personality at
96 percent i'd never heard that before
this is an interesting thought for
everybody that's listening as well and
yourself
do you think given the
current political and cultural furor
around
bodies determining gender and sex do you
think that people would be more insulted
by you taking an inventory of their body
proportions and determining it from that
or from their personality
yeah people people feel like their
personality is part of their their soul
and so i think people are also they know
that they can change their minds about
their personality but there are studies
that have been done that they say you
know if you're a bigger stronger man
you're more likely to not tolerate
people scrounging from you you're less
likely to be generous
you're less likely to be in favor of
things like um
welfare things like that and so uh
these studies that have shown that
you're able to tell a lot about
somebody's beliefs in psychology on the
basis of their face
what people are calling the new
phrenology right this is going to take
off governments are going to be using
this
you can absolutely predict things about
somebody's psychology on the basis of
their face
uh people are you know if you if you if
i show you a 10 second clip of somebody
without sound
you'll be able to tell me whether or not
they're gay or straight with like 70
accuracy there's like all of us
you know when people talk about knowing
your gut or having a gut feeling about
somebody
that's not something that's spiritual or
that is something special about being
human
a computer can do that a computer can
take in
all of the heuristics that humans are
using to make imperfect decisions
and determine with some accuracy whether
somebody's a psychopath
or somebody's generous or somebody's
going to be monogamous
these are all things that are going to
be possible looking at people
physiologically in the future
and people are horrified by that because
of stuff that they can't do anything
about
that's a really good point i think this
is one of the reasons why i've fallen in
love so much with evolutionary
psychology
my uh academic awakening
has been quite late i would say i'm a
late bloomer um
especially given the fact i was at uni
for five years i just did a subject that
i thought was [ __ ] [ __ ]
um and spent a lot of money pointlessly
but my loving evolutionary psychology is
that it allows us to see
kind of it's as close to seeing things
for what they are
i think as it can be and that to me is
fascinating like i read
like the book that made me fall in love
with it is the moral animal
and um every other page i'm just reading
this
thing like this how to create a human
document like from first principles
that's just explaining how all of this
stuff happens
and it does come up against the idea
that we're a sovereign free will
and i can imagine why people find that
to be uncomfortable to me
every time that i discover why
it's painful why it's more painful to
lose a child that's 10 years old than
one that's 3 or 17.
that totally blew my mind because
they're the closest that they could be
to being almost to be fertile and you've
lost them and your genetic heritage is
gone
and you just like there's so much of
that that i didn't know
and although it's like obviously that
particular example is tragic
think of a non-tragic example isn't that
[ __ ] interesting and cool
like you must have doing the research
that you do you must be
endlessly engaged and fascinated
yeah i mean my own behavior my own
responses
are endlessly fascinating to me just
i i sometimes feel like i you know i'm
an alien who's been reincarnated as a
human woman
and someday i'll have to give a report
about what it was like and how weird it
was
being in this body in this time in this
mind
and and having the thoughts that i do
and
it it's i think something that people
really uh really miss out on
when they're unwilling to look at
themselves
with this often very cynical perspective
uh for somebody to say
you can't possibly know the pain that i
feel you can't possibly know why
i'm interested in this person and not
interested in that person it's
you know it's a mystical experience
people won't necessarily use the word
mystical but there is this attitude
of willful ignorance around people's own
behavior
and psychology i was just uh listening
to this
this dating coach talking about how
there's all these women who want to get
married before they're 40
and they're not dating online they're
hoping they're going to like meet a man
at the grocery store or whatever
and people are often so unwilling to be
tactical
about things matters of of love
and life and psychology because
they don't want to look themselves in
the face they don't want to
say you know this is very unlikely to
work they don't want to think tactically
rationally strategically about things
that are supposed to be
ephemeral beautiful spiritual
[Music]
that's dumb because i'm i'm
i'm more than prepared to
spend all of my time walking in and out
of whole foods in america
speaking really loudly in a british
accent because i know it's a competitive
advantage when i'm ready to start a
family
like i've used all of the things i've
got like if you've managed to make it
to your 30s and you want to have a
family
spend a bit of time assessing your
strengths and just
annihilate people with them like another
thing here's something i put i put this
in my news i put this in my newsletter
a couple of weeks ago i think
personally because i've spent a lot of
time meditating i just broke a thousand
days congratulations chris
um i've spent a lot of time
honestly but yeah whatever
i thought it was good i've spent a lot
of time i've spent a lot of time
meditating i'm still
mostly terrible at it but sometimes i
get interesting insights into the
texture of my mind
15 minutes a day that's sam harris's
thing 15 minutes a day
every day um but
without evolutionary psychology
particularly it could be something else
there could be something else that could
come in its place perhaps a sufficient
understanding of psychiatry or
psychology or whatever
might give you this me learning
the tiny sliver i have of eve psych has
reframed
so much of my mindfulness practice in a
way that i find incredibly beneficial
because it a lot of what i needed and
there may be people listening that
are a little bit more sort of cerebral
like me or perhaps just have a strong
inner monologue
i needed the context i needed the
justification
of why the question of why was so strong
to me that simply being able to observe
things appear in consciousness wasn't
enough
i needed to understand why they were
there do you do you
sort of get the point i'm making yeah so
i've
done three 10-day retreats um actually
they were all in the uk
and the kinds of insane ruminations that
you have
when you're on retreat are baffling and
also i've never wanted to be out of my
own skin and another person like i've
never been so sick of myself
as i was on retreat and so you do have a
sense of that when you do a 15 minute
meditation
but you know for example i i had you
know i'm not really a very jealous
person i had jealous rumination
that lasted like three days where i was
like having this conversation with
myself over and over again until i
made myself so sick of myself this woman
told me this pregnant woman
who was on retreat with me told me that
she was playing and playing and playing
over and over in her head again and
again
an argument that she had with her best
friend who used all of the hot water
showering before her they had an
argument
that was what she was playing her hand i
thought that she was pregnant she'd be
like thinking about baby
names or like what her fiance was doing
in amsterdam that weekend
or whatever maybe that's what i would be
ruminating about and so we all have
um the things that we are are ruminating
about
and buddhism has a whole language for
what these
little you know mental demons are but
absolutely i agree that an evolutionary
psychology perspective
is really explanatory and also
helps you figure out okay of course i'm
thinking about this stuff all the time
this is stuff that's you know sitting
here thinking of nothing is the last
thing that my my mind wants to do
but until i can hold my evolved
psychology at arm's length
i'm going to be too into it to actually
figure out what's going on
yeah very much so i think
anyone that wants to understand their
own mind and there's a lot of people
listening who are very similar to
to myself in that regard because they
keep on listening apparently um
i think that the framing of evolutionary
psychology can go a long way to helping
you self-actualize
um because it just allows you to peer
into your own source code and there's
not
there's not many subject areas i think
that do that look diana thank you
for coming on people want to nosey
around with your stuff
where should they go i have a
twitter that has all my links it's at
sentientist
that's s-e-n-t-i-e-n-t-i-s-t
i'm at diana fleischmann.com that has my
links and then i also blog a couple
places uh one of them is dianaverse
where there will be blog about the
kinkova changer personality topic
amazing thank you very much i'm looking
forward to getting you back on to work
out can you train your boyfriend when's
that out when are you doing that
uh it's it's taking ages so i will not i
should have even never told anyone i was
even writing it but
can you hurry can you hurry up please
i'll speak to you on behalf of your
publisher as well yeah can you hurry up
thank you
you